herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren zu einem neuen blog auf meinem
kanal sein handy
wir fahren jetzt mal los ich habe keine
ahnung was es heute schon video gehört
soll so ein schwerverbrecher verfahren
cabriolet
wir fahren jetzt nur zeit mit köln es
ist auch der lautschrift nicht auch mal
ganz gut gegen die bühne werfen ich weiß
nicht was das heutige video fertig würde
sammelt erstmals anderen rheinseite und
schauen uns in thomas teile firma ich
habe gekauft und 90
das produziert also ich bin ich zweimal
gelaufen
guck mal da die kinder einfach sondern
man kann auch einfach den schlitten
setzen
sandra will sich jetzt von den berg
herunter rollen klassiker die kameras
heftig war dass ich bin sandra hier auch
bauer so frage ich nicht öfter diese
kamera ist richtig geil sind jetzt hier
an dem rheinstrand hieß wurde er war
angekommen ich hab keine ahnung wie das
heißt aber ich finde sie richtig schön
ich war ja öfter mal hin und setzen wir
einfach hierhin und denkt nach das leben
eigentlich das noch nie gemacht
das macht die da hinten verloren
die just follow up ja und was macht ihr
sonntag so geht das hier ist einfach so
ein richtiger stock wird dem man sich
früher als kind so eine fläche gebaut
hat kommt also nehmen dann so gummiband
dazwischen messe und dann könnte ich dir
ins gesicht
da würde ich auch sagen ich dachte das
wär jetzt bereits hier ein fotoshooting
machen
im außenbild
jetzt schön hell das sieht übrigens
heftig aus
aber wenn du schaffst innerhalb der
nächsten 20 sekunden zu dem fall dazu
kommen gibt es für eur 1 2343 sachen
speziell was die alles für zwei euro
macht ne unfassbar
guck mal leute wenn nicht wenn man im
handy hier schon runter 2 besteht hier
schon als vorschlag sender eine
nachricht an sandra und dann einfach das
foto von nicht gefunden und das bin ich
ja so damals die kassen trägt deswegen
will sie uns letzten trick zeigen
was ist falsch wird dieser frau ja ich
bin back junge was ist falsch mit ihr
wie kann ein mensch denn so um rasche wo
war das jetzt überhaupt denn trägt und
machen jetzt so coole aufnahme jetzt
macht ein trick du bist einfach gesucht
auf dem scooter sind einfach aus wie so
ein russischer gangster boss sucht 51
die stimmung ist brauche ich gerne
untersander at hot hot hot hot die jungs
über 20 jungs nelken wir haben da kriegt
ja vielleicht eine anfrage ich brauche
zeugnis fans kann man 900 ob da nicht
rein
da ist ein gullydeckel
wo fahren jetzt hin die russen und ich
sind jetzt am bahnhof angekommen schön
parkticket halbe stunde drei euro
danke dafür deutschland seine
berühmtheit verdankt ihr allerdings
weniger seiner größe aus herrschte
reichen hoch poetischen erklärt uns
gerade den kölner dom ich habe
informationen für euch habe es ist ja
eine frage an die einheit
wer hat die hunde sind echt unnormal süß
alter wir sind am kölner dom angekommen
freunde das ding ist wirklich groß krass
ja wenn ich mir vorstelle eigentlich
noch mal heftig da ist anderer natürlich
zumal er an falls sie nicht erkennen
könnt ich setze mich klein darstellte
ich war foto gerade schön hier
ich hab noch nie so richtig im kölner
dom sondern das nicht
was von den ganzen sachen die hier sind
kannst du dir leisten
warte ich kann er hat im moment jetzt
jetzt bist du drauf stark oder sagen wir
dass da vorne ist der rolex deutschland
was macht dieser typ davor oder der
einfach so eine kugel steht sie mitten
auf der straße hält so die autos an
was das auch mal sandra sehr gut wir
sind anders traumort angekommen
pommesbude und mit mario daneben
bestellte mit bayerns darauf etwas
bringt er uns wissen im mai aufgrund
klitschko ist es auch nicht
meisterschaft
hier klicken
seine schärfste currywurst habe aber
nicht so scharfe ich halte mit luxus
alter und wichtigsten feier zurück zum
podcast folgen eben leute aus
deutschland es ist wieder soweit ist
donnerstag und hier begrüßt euch ganz
ganz herzlich und kommst mit einem
mähdrescher zu mir ist mir bei der arge
da wirst du die notlage damit uns also
auf der ganzen und kopfschmerzen die
jugendschützer in der schnapsflasche
kürzen wir haben fast fertig aufgenommen
ist aber das wurde was sich damals
gewünscht darauf dass wir beide aus
diesen werken jeden fall fahren wir
jetzt zusagen zur abdel jalil schenkels
weil wir jetzt mit den videos noch
aufnehmen werden und zwar stimmt dies
auch da und da haben wir sind
[Musik]
wir sind bayern angekommen
bei aktuell und die katzen aber neuen
baum gekommen das sind die baustellen
kopfhörer wenn du die aufsätze dann
hörst einfach gar nichts mehr drumherum
krass oder
du bastard dann freut sich jetzt über
eine fast alle dann willst du kommentar
sagen du riechst nach bootshaus acht
stunden am stück
ja und nein wir haben videos ende
aufgenommen und fahren ja zu mcdonald's
dabei hat sich zwei zigaretten geschmack
bei update der die erste kaputt gemacht
und dann hat sie die zweite auto kaputt
gehört dieses bild beschreibt dein leben
einfach perfekt ein bild keinen sinn
lukas war ein video zu wie du siehst du
nämlich auswendig donalds baumesse also
der richtiges fest weil hier zwei
hundehalter galt das auch recht anmaßend
abschreiben oder so
er ist extra heute abend um gekommen um
die beste pizza dem vorjahr nur die
wirklichen abholen das war's ich finde
die dinge ist die teller ist megageil
von na ja genau
[Musik]
da kann ich doch noch kamera zu sehr gut
und hat einfach mal die texte geklaut
warte ich nehme die jetzt keine gewähr
das schaffst du nicht weißt was wir
jetzt mal vergessen haben passende
firmen blog zu dringen
das wars vom blog es ist jetzt wieder
der nächste tag sein da ist immer noch
hier weil wir jetzt der shooting haben
für die neuen dick und doof sachen im
ersten zwölf den shop kommen da kommt
luca mertes mal die sachen aber erst 12
15 uhr
[Musik]
das ist auf jeden fall gerne einen
daumenbruch unter dem video hier da wenn
ihr noch kein teil der nutzerseite davon
jedoch gerne einen kanal und schreibt
mir mal und in die kommentare
ja schon in die kommentare nicht mehr
folgen soll
aber wer bereit ist mein leben besteht
nur schwachsinn deswegen
[Musik]
b